In diesem Sommer kommt ein bemerkenswerter Film in die deutschen Kinos. Copa 71, die Geschichte der Frauen-WM in Mexico. In diesem Tribugengespräch stellen wir euch den Film kurz vor und führen ein Interview mit den beiden Regisseuren. Los geht's.
The proper place in history, role models for the coming generation. And that's not too much to show there.
Das Tribunengespräch . Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und heute möchte ich euch Copa 71 vorstellen. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an unser Tribünengespräch zu Fußballfilmen. Ist jetzt schon sechs Jahre her, haben wir im Jahr 2019 aufgenommen mit Ina Bargmann und Birger Schmidt habe ich damals gesprochen über Fußballfilme. Und schon damals haben wir unter anderem festgestellt, dass Frauen kaum eine Rolle spielen in Fußballfilmen oder noch viel zu wenig. Zum Glück hat sich da jetzt ein bisschen was schon getan in den letzten Jahren. Und in dieser Reihe steht auch die heutige Sendung. Die Sendung von damals ist aber nicht weniger hörenswert geworden in den letzten sechs Jahren. Ich verlinke sie euch nochmal in den Show Notes. Der Film, über den wir jetzt sprechen, der ist schon aus dem Jahr 2023, er kommt aber jetzt im Juni 2025 in deutsche Kinos. Und deshalb hat mich auch der Filmverleih kontaktiert und mir angeboten, den Film vorab zu sehen. Das habe ich sehr, sehr gerne gemacht. Und weil mir die Duco wirklich ganz ausgezeichnet gefallen hat, gibt es dazu nun auch eine kleine Sendung. Also worum geht es? Vielleicht habt ihr direkt oder indirekt schon mal eine Berührung mit dem Turnier gehabt. Das Gegenstand des Films ist, ich zumindest kann mich daran erinnern, dass rund um die ganzen Tweets und Posts und so weiter vom unter anderem FC Barcelona zum meistbesuchten Frauenfußballspiel der Geschichte es immer mal wieder Leute gab, die darauf hingewiesen haben, nein, nein, das stimmt nicht. Denn 1971, da gab es das Finale der WM und das war im ausverkauften Aztekenstadion vor über 100.000 ZuschauerInnen, wahrscheinlich so 110.000 könnten sogar gewesen sein, wurde das durchgeführt. Also das war was, das hat man in den letzten Jahren hin und wieder mal gesehen. Vorher allerdings, da war dieses Turnier für ganz, ganz viele vergessen. Und auch die Spielerinnen, die damals daran beteiligt waren, die dachten eigentlich dieses Turnier wäre vergessen gewesen. Dieses Turnier gilt als inoffizielle WM. Na ja, warum inoffiziell? Wir wissen ja, weil FIFA und Landesverbände in ihrer unvergleichlichen Fragienmännlichkeit den Frauenfußball damals noch verboten hatten. Es gab ihn natürlich trotzdem, aber eben nicht innerhalb der Verbandsstrukturen und unter erheblichen Repressionen. Vereine durften ihre Fußballplätze nicht zur Verfügung stellen, Schiedsrichter durften keine Spiele pfeifen und so weiter und so fort. Das alles hat ja auch mehrmals stattgefunden. Also im Grunde immer dann, wenn der Fußball der Frauen Erfolg hatte, so wie zum Beispiel in den 1920er Jahren, da gab es in Liverpool ein ganz bekanntes Spiel, wo mindestens 50.000 ZuschauerInnen zu Gast waren und sich ein Spiel angesehen haben von eben Frauenteams, die gegeneinander angetreten sind. Angeblich sollen sogar bis zu 15.000 noch vor den Stadiontoren wieder kehrt gemacht haben, weil sie zurückgeschickt wurden, weil kein Platz mehr war. Das führte damals übrigens in den 1920er Jahren, 1921, zum Verbandsverbot in England. Der DFB war da nicht minder rückständig, wer hätte es gedacht, auch wenn es dort bis zum offiziellen Verbandsverbot bis zum Jahr 1955 dauerte. Aber wir alle wissen, Fußball gespielt wurde von Frauen trotz aller Steine im Weg dennoch. Und deswegen spreche ich jetzt auch immer von der WM in Mexiko, weil mir ist es egal, ob das inoffiziell ist. Natürlich ist die Qualifikation nicht vergleichbar mit anderen Turnieren und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich sehe jetzt eigentlich nicht ein, warum man sich da an die FIFA dran hängen müsste in diesem Fall. Um diese Zeit nach dem Krieg, da geht es jetzt auch bei dieser Dokumentation. Nicht mit einem Fokus auf Deutschland, erkläre ich gleich noch. Aber mit etwas Glück, drückt mir die Daumen, wird dazu auch noch ein Tribüngespräch an dieser Stelle erscheinen. Hoffentlich in Kürze schon. Aber da kann ich euch noch nichts Genaues zu sagen, denn ich weiß es zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme noch nicht. Für den Moment werfen wir jetzt aber in dieser Sendung kurz den Blick zurück nach Mexiko im Jahr 1970. Nach der sehr erfolgreichen Männer-WM eben in genau jenem Jahr, wollte man mit den vorhandenen Stadien und der Fußballbegeisterung vor Ort zusätzliches Geld verdienen. Weshalb eine Gruppe von Männern beschloss, die zweite Weltmeisterschaft der Frauen auszurichten. Die erste fand nämlich schon im Jahr 1970, also in diesem Jahr in Italien, statt. Und natürlich ist es wichtig für die FIFA, dass die immer drauf rumreiten, dass es inoffiziell ist. Aber wie wir das hier handhaben, das habe ich euch ja gerade schon gesagt. Ich spreche jetzt einfach immer von der Weltmeisterschaft, egal ob das nach heutigen Maßstäben genauso durchgeführt worden wäre, dieses Turnier, weil ich finde, dass im Wort inoffiziell eine Art Abwertung drinsteckt und die möchte ich eigentlich an der Stelle ungern machen. Also nach der WM 1970 in Italien, die vom Unternehmen Martini und Rossi gesponsert wurde, ja das ist die Alkoholmarke, wurde ein ähnliches Turnier für das Jahr darauf geplant. Neu waren aber vor allem die Dimensionen. Gespielt wurde in Guadalajara in einem Stadion mit einer Kapazität von über 70.000 Plätzen und im Azteken Stadion mit einer Kapazität von über 100.000 Plätzen. Sechs Teams haben sich für die WM 71 qualifiziert und wollten auch teilnehmen. Das Team von Westdeutschland zum Beispiel hatte darauf verzichtet, nachdem er 1970 in Italien noch teilgenommen hatte. Das heißt, wir sprechen hier über ein Turnier ohne deutsche Beteiligung. Am Ende reisten dann neben Mexiko die Nationalteams von Argentinien, England, Dänemark, Italien und Frankreich nach Mexiko und die Mexikanerinnen waren natürlich Gastgeberinnen. Deswegen habe ich das jetzt so etwas komisch formuliert. Und um euch einen kleinen Eindruck sowohl von der Dokumentation zu geben als auch von den Spielerinnen spiele ich hier mal zwei kurze Passagen aus dem Film ein, in dem die englische Nationalspielerin Carol Wilson erzählt, auf welchem Weg sie in den 1950er Jahren dem Fußball verbunden bleiben konnte. Der O-Ton ist auf Englisch. Ich werde euch danach aber nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, was sie gesagt hat.
You were expected to get married, settle down and have kids and cook. That's about it. I didn't want to do that, so I joined the Air Force. I thought, I bet if I joined the Air Force, they'll be able to play football there. At lunchtime, I used to play five a side with the lads. This one day, I saw a load of girls starting to play in the next.
Wo wart ihr mein ganzes Leben? Das war das, was sie am Schluss gesagt hat. Also ich fasse es noch mal ganz kurz zusammen. Sie sagt eingangs, naja, damals wurde von dir als Frau erwartet, dass du kochst und dich um den Haushalt kümmerst und sie wollte aber dem Fußball verbunden bleiben und dachte der beste Weg dafür wäre zur Royal Air Force zu gehen, zur Luftwaffe also, weil man da eben weiter Fußball spielen konnte. Und als sie da mal in so einem 5 gegen 5 Spiel gespielt hat, war auf dem Nebenplatz ein reines Frauenteam und ihr ist es wie Schuppen von den Augen gefallen, dass es so etwas überhaupt gibt. Ich glaube, so in aller Kürze kann man diesen Ton so zusammenfassen. Und ich spiele euch dieses Zitat auch deshalb ein, weil das die Erfahrung aller Spielerinnen im Film ist. Jede von ihnen liebte den Fußball so sehr, dass sie ihn aller Widerstände zum Trotz selbst gespielt hat, um dann irgendwann festzustellen, dass sie damit nicht alleine ist. Und dieses Where have you been all my life, das ist dann so ein bisschen stellvertretend für den Blick von vielen, die in dieser Dokumentation zu Wort kommen. Und allein für den Blick, den sie dabei hat, als sie das sagt, da lohnt sich der Film meiner Meinung nach schon. Ich sag's euch, er ist wunderschön und traurig auch zugleich. Er macht einen auch wütend, aber dazu kommen wir auch noch mal. Die Frauen finden sich also, sie spielen Fußball, sie pfeifen auf die Verbote und all den Spott, den sie natürlich auch aushalten müssen und organisieren sich in Teams und Ligen. Und das in vielen Ländern. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie ähnlich sich die Geschichten sind, die innerhalb der Dokumentation erzählt werden. Ich will es jetzt nicht vorwegnehmen, aber ihr werdet es selbst merken, wenn ihr den Film seht. Und ähnlich ist es dann auch, was die Überforderung der Teams angeht bei der Ankunft in Mexiko. Wegen der besseren Verständlichkeit habe ich wieder ein O-Ton auf Englisch mitgebracht, denn die anderen Teams haben auch davon erzählt. Aber ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, die meisten von euch verstehen eher noch Englisch als Italienisch oder Spanisch. Wir hören jetzt also die Reaktion der englischen Spielerinnen auf ihre Ankunft. Da liegt noch Musik back drunter. Ich habe auch etwas geschnitten, um es für den Podcast zu optimieren. Also lasst euch davon nicht irritieren. Ihr habt es gehört, Frauen, die noch nie in ihrem Leben geflogen sind, begeben sich auf die Reise nach Mexiko und werden vom Blitzlichtgewitter der Fotografen vor Ort empfangen. Das ist nämlich das, was nicht nur außergewöhnlich ist, sondern diesen Film erst möglich gemacht hat. Die Veranstalter in Mexiko haben viel Geld investiert, um Berichterstattung möglich zu machen. Jedes Team wurde nicht nur mit Klamotten, Fußballschuhen usw. ausgestattet, sondern auch von einem eigenen Fotografen oder einer Fotografin begleitet. Über viele Seiten hinweg berichteten damals die Zeitungen. Es gab Bilder und Fotos zu sehen, die Spiele wurden übertragen im Radio und im Fernsehen. Und für die Doku ist das natürlich ein Segen. Denn allein dadurch, dass man Bilder sehen kann, vom vorhin Aztekenstadion zum Beispiel, das hat eine ganz andere Wirkmacht als nur darüber zu lesen. Und auch die Begeisterung der Fans vor Ort zu sehen, das ist das Magische an diesem Film, würde ich fast sagen. Immer wieder der Gegenschnitt des Leuchten in den Augen der Protagonistin bei der Erinnerung an dieses Turnier. Und dann im Gegenschnitt dazu sieht man dann eben das Leuchten in den Augen von manchem Zuschauer und mancher Zuschauerin vor Ort. Und natürlich ist es noch auch eine interessante Lehre. Wer hätte das gedacht, dass der Fußball der Frauen Erfolg haben könnte, wenn man in ihn investiert? Mensch, liegt da vielleicht eine versteckte Botschaft für die Gegenwart drin? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich will euch jetzt nicht den Film nach erzählen. Und es ist auch wichtig zu sagen, dass dieses ganze Turnier nicht aus altruistischen Gründen veranstaltet wurde. Es ging darum, Geld zu verdienen und die Stadien der WM 1970, also der Männer-WM, weiter zu nutzen. Und dieses Geld wurde auch unter anderem damit verdient, ganz explizit mit sexistischen Motiven, indem man gesagt hat, kommt nicht nur um Fußball zu sehen, sondern kommt auch um Zitat schöne Girls, also schöne Mädchen zu sehen beim Fußballspielen. Das wird auch in der Doku angesprochen. Ich habe da allerdings auch in dem Gespräch, was ihr gleich noch hören werdet, schon noch ein, zwei Nachfragen zu gehabt. Aber ich kann euch sagen, die Begeisterung der Spielerinnen, die sich in der Doku an dieses für sie einmalige Erlebnis erinnern, die ist wirklich ansteckend und macht auch gleichzeitig wütend. Denn nach der WM 1971 ging es nicht in diesem Maßstab weiter, ganz im Gegenteil. Auch darüber habe ich mit den beiden Regisseurinnen des Films Copper 71 gesprochen, James Urkens und Rachel Ramsay. Dieses Interview spiele ich euch jetzt dann ein. Es wurde komplett auf Englisch geführt. Wer ein deutsches Transkript zum Gespräch benötigt, der findet es in den Show Notes. Und wie ihr es gewohnt seid, habe ich nicht geschnitten und es ganz veröffentlicht, meinem etwas holprigen Englisch zum Trotz. Dennoch wünsche ich euch jetzt viel Spaß mit diesem Gespräch über den Film Kopper 71. So, Rachel and James, welcome to the Rasenfunk. Glad that you are here.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for having us. I suppose you have many projects ongoing and you're in a lot of different topics inside your head and you started working on this documentary during COVID. It aired on 2023. So what are your feelings revisiting Kopper 71 now?
Well, I think whenever you get very deep into a story like this and a particular story that's new, so we did all the original research ourselves. We found all the contributors, all the women who participated in the original 1971 tournament. So a big part of that early process was building up relationships with the women who played and hearing their stories. And I think the chance to revisit going back to that is always a huge pleasure. It does feel like a little while ago now, but we hope that we've made something that stands the test of time, that doesn't feel too dated.
And does it have a special place in your heart, in your working business because of all the effort that went into it?
Yeah, I mean, of course, every film is like a child. You want to love all your children. But yeah, this one, I think, was particularly profound because it meant so much to the contributors. These were women whose voices hadn't been heard for half a century. And to be able to help with their memories and bring the tournament back into public consciousness was highly significant and felt very rewarding. Often with a story, you know, stories are already out there. This one, it really felt like we were, we were not only making the story for the audience and for ourselves, but also for the people, people within the film.
As I understand it, your starting point was a BBC documentary about it. And from there on, you got the idea to do this film. And many years later or many months later, it appeared on the screens. What does it say that almost nobody knew about this tournament?
Well, yeah, the original idea came from interviews that the British, the English team were having to try and reunite after 50 years. They hadn't spoken to each other in 50 years. And there was a brilliant BBC journalist, Ian Youngs, who helped facilitate this. And he wrote a great article which we saw. And he started to introduce us to those women. And then we found that in other countries, there was a journalist here and there who may have done some work already on the team applicable to their country. Bringing those all together felt very natural, and there was a huge amount of support from that. But yeah, really, the idea that no one had covered it yet was because no one thought it worth covering on the bigger scale. This was a tournament played by women a long time ago, and they felt like that wasn't actually a particularly interesting and or relevant story, which we hope we proved not to be the case.
And then some kind of detective job started for you. You had to find not also information about this tournament, starting with newspapers mostly, but also clips and moving images of this tournament. Could you have told this story as a film without these clips that you found in this material?
No, I mean, I think the Archive is essential to telling the story. Obviously, part of validating the tournament's existence is to show the material and prove it so that it becomes undeniable. You know, people have tried to pretend this tournament didn't happen for a very long time. This stuff had been locked away and lost. And, you know, over a long period of time, we pieced together bits of footage to be able to tell this story. But we also wanted to make sure that the film had plenty of archive of it, so that you couldn't dismiss it as being a, which it had been, as being a small event, an irrelevant event, once you sort of show that there's, you know, over 100,000 people in the stadium and you can see them, you can see the match, you can see the energy of the football then, and you show that enough times, then people, the classic arguments against women's football and what it was und was es ist, start to fade away. Just as people who watch an international match at the Euros this year will see, it's a proper full-blooded sport and not what people have tried to ascribe to it as something lesser in the past. So that was really important to us to see that it really mattered to the people there, the audiences and also the players. And just to see the sort of the sporting accidents, the fire in everyone's belly and the determination to win.
Yeah, and the fact that we had that footage and could build the world, you really allow the audience to feel like they're there, to really feel like they're part of the stadium. And you hear how the women describe the sound and the heat and the excitement of the tournament itself. And if you can really show that and invite them in, invite the audience in, especially with everything from the sound design to having to colourise some of that footage. So that was all having that original footage was what really, I think, makes it incredibly special.
And where did you find all this footage?
It was it was it was it was it was pieced together from all over the world. We found it from private sources. We found it little bits of tape here and there. Some of the women themselves had tapes of some of the matches. It was it was a big detective job that really only came together in the last couple of weeks of the edit. When we were able to find about 18 minutes of footage that was held by a private individual in Mexico whose grandfather had been there filming the event at the time on Super 8.
Wow, Super 8. Talk about colouring and recolouring this film, but this is the more technical aspect. What was the most surprising thing you found storytelling wise seeing all this footage and then later talking to the players?
I think one of the most surprising things was how much connection these women still had, even not speaking for 50 years, how that formative experience when they were so young has really shaped how they still see the world, how they connect with each other. There's a real sense of sisterhood across all of it. Their backgrounds were all quite similar, whether they were from rural Mexico or from Buenos Aires or from industrial England. There was something very similar in the way that they spoke about their desire to play when they were young. They spoke about how angry it had made them when they were denied playing and how ashamed they all felt. These series of emotions that you feel throughout the film really were something that were given to us in the interviews. This is not something that we had planned. You ask them how they felt and the similarities were incredible. And also the ability to remember. Their memories. We didn't show them any of the footage. All of their memories of those games are things that are inscribed on their memories, even though they hadn't talked about it in 50 years.
And although getting the players to talk about the tournament wasn't easy, why?
Well, I think the players were still... This level of shame that they felt was something that I think had almost sort of increased, sort of become more intense over the years. So when we first approached them, they didn't really believe that we wanted to take them seriously. They didn't really believe that someone was finally interested in their story after 50 years. And they were quite careful. And you'll speak to, if you hear interviews with any of the players that were done, they will say, you know, the first time that we called them up, they thought, well, who is this people? Why are they calling from England? What does this mean? What does this mean for us? And we talk about the fact that the age they're at, the first initial conversations were during COVID, so it was impossible to go and visit in person. So a lot of stuff was done over the phone, getting the women lined up with Zoom with the help of their family members and starting very slowly to build those relationships and encouraging that they could trust us. This was a story that not only did we want to hear, but we were going to really throw a lot of resources and a lot of care at.
And you said that for some players, the tournament was a trauma. Can you expand on that?
Well, I think the tournament itself wasn't a trauma. The tournament itself was a wonderful odyssey into what the world could be like. I think the trauma was when people came home and they were told, well, they were humiliated in the press, certainly in England, when they were told that they couldn't play football any more, then they were told that memories didn't exist. I think gaslighting is at the heart of it. So, yeah, that's where the trauma comes from. The trauma doesn't come from having a brilliant time and being given what you've already wanted. The trauma comes from not only having that taken away from you, but being told that it didn't exist in the first place and that you were delusional. So, that's where the trauma comes.
And that could be also the reason why some of them even did not talk to their family about their experiences. That was one thing that surprised me or shocked me, to be honest, when I read about you talking about your documentary. Some grandchildren didn't even know that their grandmom was playing this tournament.
Yeah, because the, as James used the word gaslighting, it's very applicable here. It was a very, it's a very deep thing to say, this has been the best day of our lives, this is what we've achieved, this is how we can see ourselves on the world stage, women's football that we've always believed in is here to stay. And then for the establishment to turn around and say, oh no, no, that's not the case anymore. It's a very fundamental thing to do to a person, to sort of take away that hope and then say, and then laugh at them for having that hope in the first place. And say, well, of course, we were never going to let women play football. Of course, it's not commercial. And so, well, yes, it was. I was there. And they kept the, one of the ways we did the early research before we could find any of the footage was the women had kept very detailed scrapbooks of all of the newspaper coverage from the time that they were in Mexico and from their home countries. And to be honest, if we hadn't seen a lot of that, we would have found it hard potentially to, you know, to really understand the scale of it ourselves. So there was, yeah, I can very much, I think, and I think it is an emotion that a lot of us can understand in our own lives. As I, you know, if you have a dream and you achieve it and then it's taken away, that's going to feel very, very damaging.
And you said after the first screening that through your documentary, the individual experience of the players shifted to a collective experience. Do you know what that meant for them? I suppose you were still in touch with them after the first screenings?
Yeah, I mean, I think, you know, obviously, their memories were conditioned by where they were stood and what they were experiencing. They hadn't got to see the tournament in the round, the scale of it. They just been focused on the football and the pitch. And so to be able to see that the other teams went through similar things and had similar backgrounds and had a similar experience, they understood the scale of it perhaps in a completely different way. And the way that we try to make the film, classically when you're making a sports film, you're rooting for one team, one country. And we very much tried to make the film. I hope that we succeeded in making the film so that you're rooting for all of them to succeed and that the journey is one collectively where, you know, not just a player wins, a team wins, a country wins, but a whole gender gets to win the thing that they've been told that they're not allowed to have, you know, at least for a few moments.
And although some parts of this tournament are like a dream, there are also some things you can clearly criticize. I think one of the most blatant aspects is the sexism in which or through which the men who earned money with this tournament marketed it. Why didn't you ask the players what they are thinking about this looking back and what they maybe thought about it during the tournament?
Well, I think the film is set in 1971. It's very much in the world. We were building the world that existed for these women at the time. This is what they had to face. We were, again, the idea of looking back at it, we're much keener to show what it actually was like to be there for them. And the idea of the press using women's bodies to sell things, we could say we can criticize it back at the time, but it's not a huge amount has necessarily changed in the last 50 years. So there's a point in saying this is the real life lived experience of these women. And to deny that or say that wasn't the case. Or that would be actually doing them a disservice. And what should also be pointed out is that of course, yes, we didn't want to shy away from showing that that was the world that they were living and what they were facing. And what added to the fact that later on this, the whole tournament is disappeared. But the other thing to say is that the coverage, which we also show, the coverage of the tournament at the time in the local newspapers, in the newspapers in Mexico City, is a sort of quadruple page color prints of the tournament and treating the women like athletes. Which again, I mean, the percentage-wise of these, of what was being put out at the time is probably bigger than is being put out in the back of newspapers right now about women's game. So there was, you know, both sides of it. And we were keen to show those nuances and let people sort of make up their own decision about what it would feel like to be there at the time.
And another critical point is money. At one point, the Mexicans tried not to play and to be compensated. But I didn't really get, if they did get something after their boycott, and I don't want to take away anything from the documentary. So the listeners outside here should see it themselves. But why wasn't this a bigger part? Because from what I took away, it was a great experience for all these women. And it was also financially a good experience because they were paid for the trip and everything was compensated. But there must have been some money earned and it didn't get to their pocket. Or am I wrong?
Well, I mean, I think, you know, that's obviously, we addressed that in the film and how some of the women felt about it. But this is a different period. This is early 1970s. You know, just like in the Olympics, you know, the Olympics is an amateur ideal. And, you know, of course, there's lots of professional athletes that compete now, especially in tennis and basketball. But back in the day, there wasn't necessarily expectation to profit from the sport. The women were not professional footballers. Professional football didn't, well, some of the Italians were. But aside from that, it didn't really exist. So, I don't think that was what the focus was. The focus was not, we need to go there to earn money, to earn a living. This is about doing the thing that you loved and having the opportunity to do that first and foremost. And yeah, at the end of the day, if someone's making a handsome amount of money out of it, then they really ought to distribute it. But that's almost a slightly different moral question. Yeah, there's sexism implied in that. But that's also the conceptions that we have about within capitalist economy, between masters and servants.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, at this point, they're still fighting for the right to be on a pitch, let alone be paid for it, to be able to get kits, the Argentinians arrive without any football boots, because they can't afford boots at the time. They borrow them, and then that's where the sisterhood comes in again. The Mexican team give them kit to play in. So there's all of these other nuances. And a lot of the themes that we've brought up throughout the film are still things that we're talking about today. So again, gender parity and pay. And it's easy to say, well, you know, how terrible it was in 1971, 50 years ago. But what we're hoping it does as well is to encourage us to look at what's going on now as well.
Yeah, that's the power of the film, I think it has in the present. And also the big question, how is it even possible to vanish the memory of one tournament like this, to make it almost disappear, almost, because of your documentary and some things that followed up to this. What are your thoughts on how this even was possible?
Well, I think it's a different era. We're in the area where things go on the internet and we have social media and things can be repeated and repeated all the time. Back then, unless a broadcaster didn't show it and they showed it once, then you didn't see it, then the tapes were not put back into circulation. So in a way, it was relatively easy to suppress that in that period of time. I mean, everything has to be looked at through the lens of time, and that's why it's important for a film like this to actually go deeper and find the original material and say, actually, what you're told about this period is completely incorrect. And here's the evidence to show it. But there would have been no reason to show it, just as there probably wasn't any particular reason to replay, you know, by Munich versus Dortmund in 1972. You know, a cup final probably wouldn't have got reshown in future years in that period.
Yeah. And also what you mentioned earlier, so you made it possible that you are rooting for other teams. And it's almost disappointing when some of them lose and they go out of the tournament. So you made your point, you achieved it, and you also use the word sisterhood sometimes now during our conversation. I could guess that this was also one of the obstacles for them. During this tournament, they were individual teams, but they experienced some sisterhood and they acknowledged that there are other women in their shoes in the metaphorical way. But back at their country, they were on their own, in their own city, in their own not existing league or self-made league. So I would think this is the big difference to now that we don't have social media and we don't have any other aspects of connection.
Yeah, I think it was easy for the women to lose the connection, especially when the infrastructure that was being built at a grassroots level throughout the 20th century for women to play. If that infrastructure was not supported, then the women do not have a way of keeping in contact with each other. And especially in the case of, it happened particularly in Denmark, particularly in England, was that the fragile ecosystem that existed at that point was then really ripped away when they got back. And I think if the football associations had genuinely leaned in at that point, I mean, that was the year that the ban on women playing on FA-affiliated pitches in England was lifted. And there's lots of different conversations around how that support was then given to female players and to the beginning of a women's football culture. But I think, because the previous 50 years had been denied, that it was taking away a lot of the roots that would have made women's football a lot stronger at that point, by people not necessarily recognizing the achievements they had so far.
As you are talking about the FA, did any of the associations, FA or even the FIFA react to your film?
Well, they were all aware that that's what we were making at the time. I mean, we had to, in order to find the footage, we were contacting everybody and anybody and finding out who really owns the tournament at the time. Because it was sponsored at the time by Martini Rossi, which has gone through the different hands now and has its own historical department, who were very helpful, but they then couldn't help us find the actual footage. We went to FIFA. They couldn't help us find the footage. It's not their tournament, as they told us. And then we did license current FIFA footage for the more modern montages and pieces. So they were well aware of what we were doing.
But other than that, no reaction to your groundwork. Okay. It speaks for itself. So what do you think? What could we take away from Copa 71? What does it need to give female soccer players the stage they deserve?
I think one of the important things is to understand that the sport has deep roots. You know, every time people try to organize and women try to organize to play the sport, they were like a tree being felled the whole time, being chopped down. And if you don't understand that things have a deep root and that you have accessibility to previous generations' enjoyment, then it seems less valid. It seems, you know, women's soccer, women's football, you know, if it begins in the 1990s, doesn't have as deep roots as a football that begins in the 1970s. The 1970s is already a global phenomenon, you know. So I think it's about validating that experience and showing that, you know, that this is things that not just, you know, you want to do, but your mum wanted to do and your grandma and your great grandma and your great grandma's grandma, you know, and that actually that right is something you have to keep fighting for.
Which is for itself astonishing. I mean, female soccer also goes back to the 1890s. And something like this, you had, I mean, I don't have to tell you this, you had this very big, almost Premier League matches from Arsenal and other clubs. And then the FA got scared and shut it down. And we have similar developments here in Germany, in Western Germany to speak. But what do you think is the takeaway concerning taking the way the players play a series and investing money in it? I mean, all the teams, for example, had their photographer. And there were a lot of photos that you also could use for your documentary, so we are very glad about it. But the investors, they did not only earn money, but they also invested money. Is that also something we should consider and keep in the back of our minds if we look at present days?
Well, yes, they saw it as a commercial opportunity. They saw that it would be football first and foremost, and that people would come and watch. And if they supported it properly, then there would be a chance for them to make a return on their investment in the women. They treated them mostly like athletes. They understood that the people would want to see the paparazzi shots of the teams. And yes, the nuances of this, it's done in a bit of a 70s lens in some cases. But the fact that they still committed to that tournament is something that I think people have been slow to, but surely are taking a lot of lessons from now.
And there are very much emotional moments during this documentary in the world of 71, but also in the present of your interviews. What were the moments where you were emotional during interviews, during seeing footage or anything else?
You know, I think we were careful, as we said, to build up relationships with the women slowly, so we got to understand them and their stories. And then when you're asking someone to tell that story on camera, again, you give them space and you give them time. And I think they will hold themselves incredibly well. You know, one of the early concerns from some people when we pitched the film was, you know, would these women who are unknown, who don't have media training, who haven't been on camera before, can they hold the narrative? Can they hold a film like this? And, you know, you only have to spend a few moments in their company on camera to know that, yes, absolutely they can. They're brilliant storytellers. They're very funny. One of the things that we've enjoyed most is coming out of screenings when people said, well, actually, that was, they're very funny. And it's like, yeah, have you met these ladies? They're completely badass. And they're amazing. They've got a lot to say. And they're not afraid to show that emotion. And that's what we always knew we needed. When you're making a film like this, you hope will be watched in cinemas and watched around the world. It's got to be an emotional journey. This isn't just a list of facts. It's not the Wikipedia entry. This is the emotional journey of these women. And they trusted us to show that. And I think all of those moments were very emotional. And then watching it with the women finally when we finished making it and having their reactions to actually seeing themselves on the big screen, obviously that was all very emotional.
And how did it come that the Williams Sisters got on board with this documentary as executive producers in a long list of producers, but since they are also on the German movie Transparent, the picture marketing the movie, I wanted to ask, how did it come that they are on board?
Well, they came on board because the film was financed by Westbrook Studios in the States, which is Will Smith's company, and Will Smith made King Richard, which was obviously the story about the Williams sisters growing up and their father. So, he had a direct relationship with them. So obviously, because he thought it was a cool story. He said it would be cool to see if Venus and Serena wanted to board and add their voice and support to the project. So, Westbrook took it to Serena and Venus and they were excited about the prospect in telling this story. They're both particularly interested in football, soccer anyway. And, you know, it just, it chined with them and they saw the value of coming on board and helping us get the film together and out into the world.
And you also tied the connections to the US soccer. So we have not only Alex Morgan talking about it and it's kind of the the circle that this documentary is telling in its storytelling arc. So we start with Brandi Castain and we come to an end with the US. And that's because of, you think, the special place US soccer and female-wise has in history?
Yeah, I think in order to contextualize women's soccer, particularly for those who don't know much about the sport, it's important to understand the role that the US plays from the early 90s until present day. In terms of looking, we wanted to find recognizable, huge figures who are hugely historically important in women's soccer from that period from the 90s. Those women at the time, really, the US had that space. So if you watch the film, you see why we've chosen to do that. I'm trying not to give away too many spoilers, but yes, it was important to, they're not part of the actual story of the tournament and they don't pop up throughout that bit, but in order to contextualize, give the tournament real weight as well and say, that we can actually set it amongst a more recognizable part of women's soccer history which involves the teams in the US from the 90s onwards.
So, one little detail I want to give it away because it is right at the beginning of the movie. So, you show Brandi Castain some footage of the 71 tournament and she doesn't know that it existed. Is this real? Did she really didn't know it until she saw the footage?
No, she had no idea. This is, I mean, this is the point. This is why we chose to go to the US as well, was to show that of all, you know, she felt very strongly. And as she says, you know, she's sort of delighted that she can see the footage at the same time as being completely furious that she didn't know it existed before and how different, you know, she was a trailblazer in her own right and believe she was the first and that she believes she was the first, not in the state, not in the case, you know, or I want to be the first, but saying, you know, she had to be. And she didn't have role models. And she's saying, you know, these women could have been my role model in the same way that I hope I've been. And that's some of the sad that some of that loss of history. And, you know, if we look back, there were women playing in the 50s and in the 40s and in the 30s and in the 20s. These all could have been, if they were given their proper place in history, role models for the coming generation, then that's something we wanted to show there.
Yeah. And to end on a positive note, you said that when you discovered this tournament and started working on your film, there was no Wikipedia entry for this tournament. But during the time you were working on it, the Internet did its thing and there is one now without your help. So you didn't do it. At least you say you didn't do it. Does this tell us anything?
I mean, I think the thing it tells you is probably the Wikipedia entry was largely built from people who watched the film and read a few other books that the consultants had written about it. I mean, you know, it's there for... What it tells us is it's there permanently now. Nobody is going to be able to say that Copa 71 didn't happen. Again, whether they watched the film or not, they can find out within a second. AI will tell them. Chat GPT will tell them that women's soccer began many more years before than they thought it did. And therefore, everybody will believe it because the Internet says so.
Yeah, but it's astonishing because that's how I discovered this tournament. We had all these so-called record-breaking games of FC Barcelona. And they always said, oh, it's the most intended famous football game. And then I saw on, I think, then it was Twitter, now it would be Blue Sky, some people saying, no, that is not true. There was this tournament in the Aztex Stadium and there were over 100,000 of fans. And that's how I learned about this tournament. And I know that the Wikipedia entry, it was existing then because that's how I read through. And that also shows how important your work can be and how important it is to just keep the memory alive. And you don't want to take away anything of the present, but it is right to be precise. And there are a lot of unofficial tournaments. I mean, we have an unofficial World Cup in which Germany took place in the 90s. We have some unofficial Euros in the 50s. 57, I guess, was this tournament. So we have to dig up all these history parts and just keep them alive. And I think that is the takeaway. You can also get off your film or am I completely wrong?
No, certainly. I think one thing we never set out to do is to make a history of women's football. This is a film about one period, about five weeks in one summer, that happens to be the highest attended women's sporting event ever. And the fact that that was disappeared is, as you say, shocking. And that's the fundamentals of the film and why this is one of the reasons it's an exciting watch. But we have since the film was made, I think last year, Guinness World Records officially recognized that final at the Azteca as the highest attended women's sporting event with over, I think, at least proving 112,000, estimating 120. And, you know, given the size of stadiums now, that's likely to stay as a record. And mentioning other unofficial tournaments. They're unofficial because they were not recognized by UEFA, by the FA, by FIFA. That doesn't mean they didn't happen. And we'd be delighted to start seeing many other films. I think I would suggest that 71 is one of the earliest you're going to be getting home movie footage from stadiums, because a lot of people have got cameras out there. But yeah, we're certainly not gatekeeping the idea of unofficial women's tournaments and what was built into that. Hopefully this is more of a gateway to prove that people do want to see this and they're interested and they want to really understand what that history is.
Rachel Ramsey and James Erskine, thank you very much for your time and for your documentary.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Coppa71 ist ab jetzt in deutschen Kinos zu sehen. Ein Link zur Übersicht der Vorstellung packe ich euch in die Show Notes. Es lohnt sich aber sicher, bei euch vor Ort nochmal nachzuschauen. Natürlich hat ein Film dieser Art Leerstellen. Ihr habt es auch im Gespräch schon gehört. Alle Aspekte können nie dargestellt werden. Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob er mir persönlich nicht zu versöhnlich endet, wenn zum Beispiel Alex Morgan, die neben den Williams Schwestern eine weitere Executive Producerin ist. Für die Gegenwart des Fußballs dann doch ein sehr rosiges Bild zeichnet. Mir kommt dabei der Skandal, was nach diesem Turnier passiert ist, deutlich zu kurz. Nicht nur gegenüber den Spielerinnen, die dort teilgenommen haben, sondern generell mit Erinnerung an dieses komplette Turnier, an diesen kompletten Wettbewerb. Denn im Grunde war es ein Ausradieren dieses Turniers. Systematisch haben Männer dieses Turnier vergessen und in die Missachtung geschoben. Und auch deshalb will ich es eben eigentlich nicht inoffizielle WM nennen, weil das so ein bisschen auch ein Teil davon ist. Und wer weiß, wie viele andere Turniere noch in ähnlicher Art und Weise aufleben könnten, wenn wir eben genauso tolle Protagonistinnen, die man interviewen könnte, dazu finden würden. Und wenn es dazu zum Beispiel dann auch das entsprechende Filmmaterial gäbe, um eben einen Film draus zu machen und eben diese Wirkmacht der Bilder zu haben, die ich vorhin auch schon angesprochen habe. Also wer weiß, wie lange das überhaupt dauern würde und ob es überhaupt möglich ist, ein halbwegs vollständiges Bild der Fußballgeschichte zu haben, denn das muss man sich immer klar machen. Wir haben bisher nur Fragmente, denn eben einen ganz großen Teil und den vor allem weiblichen Teil, den kennen wir eben dann doch nicht. Alle guten Versuche zutrotz an der Stelle, ganz, ganz herzliche Grüße an Legende verloren. Wenn ihr diesen Podcast noch nicht hört, dann hört da definitiv rein. Obwohl es diese Leerstelle gibt und obwohl es natürlich noch ganz, ganz viele Anschlussthemen an diese Dokumentation gäbe, finde ich es aber trotzdem gut, die Entscheidung, sich auf das Turnier und die Protagonistin zu fokussieren. Die Spiele werden durch ihre Augen wiederbelebt und aus ihrer Perspektive erinnern wir uns alle daran. Und das gefällt mir deshalb, weil das die wichtigste Perspektive ist, nämlich das, was mit den Spielerinnen damals passiert ist. Und ihr habt es ja auch dann vorhin im Interview schon mit Rachel und James gehört. Es ist eben nicht nur eine positive Erfahrung für die Spielerinnen. Und umso schöner, finde ich es, wenn dann durch diesen Film, nach allem, was man sieht und was man auch lesen konnte, auch im Nachgang nach den ersten Veröffentlichungen, dieser Film hat auch einige Preise gewonnen, unter anderem auch beim 11-Millimeter-Fußballfilm-Festival in Berlin. Wenn jetzt im Nachhinein dann diese Erinnerung, die für manche Frauen aufgrund dessen, was nach ihrer Ankunft in den jeweiligen Ländern passiert ist, dass sie eben komplett gesperrt wurden, dass sie nicht begrüßt wurden am Flughafen, sondern eben ganz im Gegenteil mit schlimmen, schlimmen Reaktionen umgehen mussten. Also wenn das eben zu einem Trauma bei einigen dieser Spielerinnen geführt hat, so wie es ja Rachel vorhin auch formuliert hat, dann ist zumindest zu hoffen, dass durch die Resonanz, die dieser Film hat und auch durch das Kollektive, was in diesem Film steckt, dass die Spielerinnen sehen, es ging ihnen nicht alleine so, dass das vielleicht diese Negativerinnerung zumindest ein Stück weit positiv besetzen kann. Und das ist dann, glaube ich, dann doch eigentlich nur möglich, wenn man sich dann auf diese Perspektive beschränkt. Wenn es etwas im Kontext zu sagen gibt, dann wird das im Film auch nicht komplett weggelassen. Und das sind dann eben auch andere Stimmen. Da hören wir eine Historikerin und ein Historiker, die sich dazu noch mal äußern und insgesamt muss ich sagen, hat mir das aber sehr gut gefallen. Denn dieser Film ist vor allem eines, er ist Freude am Spiel, er ist Unglaube über die Dimension dieses Turniers, obwohl man es eigentlich schon hätte wissen müssen, ist es nochmal was anderes, es zu sehen. Zumindest mir ging es so. Es ist Wut über das, was den Frauen vor und nach dieser WM angetan wurde. Und es ist aber auch ein bisschen pathetisch, ich gebe es zu, aber es ist die Hoffnung, dass so etwas nicht nochmal passieren kann. Dass es nicht nochmal Männern gelingt, Frauen aus dem Fußball zu drängen. Da sind wir hoffentlich jetzt dann doch weiter. Mich würde sehr interessieren, was ihr über diesen Film denkt. Mich würde natürlich auch interessieren, was ihr zu einer Folge dieser Art, so haben wir das jetzt auch noch nie gemacht, im Rasenfunk denkt. Gebt uns gerne Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und ansonsten wisst ihr ja, wie ihr uns erreicht. Und auch eine Folge wie diese hier ist komplett von euch finanziert. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt Paywall Werbe und Sponsoren frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich dabei bedanken bei Martin SCF, bei Flümle, bei mir San Moin und bei Dani. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de gegangen und haben auf den Unterstützen Button geklickt. Und wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr genau dort. Es geht via Direktüberweisung, via Paypal, via Kreditkarte, Apple Pay, Google Pay. Wir haben wirklich alles. In diesem Sinne, herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Schreibt mir gerne, wie ihr den Film fandet, wenn ihr ihn gesehen habt. Und ansonsten hören wir uns hoffentlich in diesem Feed bald wieder. Wenn dem so wäre, dann wären wir alle, glaube ich, glücklich. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke für eure Unterstützung des Rasenfunks. Bleibt uns gewogen, bleibt gesund. Empfehlt uns weiter und bis bald. Ciao.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.